until recently they were helping
refugees in greece now a group of aid
workers is on trial accused of spying
and many other charges but is this
politically motivated and what does it
mean for aid work worldwide this is
inside story
[Music]
hello and welcome to the program i am
hashem
more than two dozen aid workers from
different nations are facing trial on
the greek island of lesbos
they're accused of helping migrants
reach greece
among them is a syrian refugee sarah
mardini who was granted asylum in
germany and is the sister of olympic
swimmer yusra mardini the two came under
international spotlight in 2015
when they dragged their boat to safety
for kilometers when its engine failed
they all stand accused of spying people
smuggling and money laundering among
other charges some could face up to 25
years in prison
they say they were only helping other
fellow humans
i never
for a moment thought that trying to help
somebody out at sea would land you in
prison pre-trial prison for three and a
half months and that one would also end
up facing 25 years in prison i'm
terrified
i'm terrified of going back to prison
there is
it is incredibly frightening
you know when we were first in patrol
detention
you're held in you're held in pre-trial
prison but you're innocent until proven
guilty
i didn't see any of innocence or being
treated like an innocent person rice
groups have condemned the trial saying
it's politically motivated
human rights watchdog amnesty
international has called the trial
farcical
we are here to say how outraged we are
that the greek government is pursuing a
criminal case as charges against these
people who did absolutely nothing wrong
sara and so on
are a typical case an exemplary case of
what's going on now in europe
dozens of people are being criminalizing
criminalized for doing the right thing
but is helping people in need helping
refugees and migrants in need police
must immediately adopt the charges
and let these two young people carry on
with their lives
we'll begin our discussion in a moment
but first let's go to john cenopolos in
athens john how do the greek people are
reacting to this particular trial
well at the moment this isn't very well
publicized the news of this is not very
widespread there are other things like
coronavirus claiming the limelight
but this is a story that's been ongoing
since september 2018 when the
indictments took place
um there is awareness very high
awareness among the humanitarian
community in the aid community and there
the reactions are
that people are appalled because
the
emergency response center international
was an aid group that was working very
closely with authorities including the
hellenic coast guard
the local authorities on lesvos the
government
they had cleared all the hurdles in
terms of registration with the
government and
following the regulations and the
national law
so
this indictment of all 30 of its members
came a little out of the blue i've
spoken
both then and more recently this year
with the lawyer representing the group
who tells me that there were
serious procedural problems with the way
these indictments were handled first of
all
the names of individuals who were
indicted were leaked to the press which
is a contravention of european privacy
law
and seems to shift the burden of proof
on to individuals and away from the
prosecutor before the trial even begins
there were leaked documents that are
being included in the indictment which
is highly irregular
and then there is the problem that the
inquisitor
issued arrest warrants before the
defendants had had a opportunity to make
a first response this is very unusual
i'm told and it's done only in cases
where there's a very serious flight risk
on the part of the defendants
critics are saying that just by the very
nature of the charges particularly
spying
could be an indication that the
government is adamant about the need to
further silence international aid
organizations operating in
greece
well as you know
those indictments
back in september of 2018
were not the only ones against
search and rescue operations
they were followed in september of 2020
by the indictment of another four groups
another 33 individuals
including groups that i have spoken to
since then
who
um also say that they were absolutely
honest with the hellenic coast guard
about their whereabouts and what they
were doing
um they usually operate vessels
that place themselves deliberately
in areas where
refugee dinghies are expected to be
found in order to alert the hellenic
coast guard to come and pick them up or
for the coast guard to ask the turkish
coast guard to go and pick them up
they they are simply there as spotters
and facilitators
so they also were very surprised uh in
september of last year
to be indicted and
they also have
uh absolutely no idea what they've done
wrong and these are very serious charges
that are being leveled their charges of
trafficking and espionage which could
land people life imprisonment sentences
uh i've been told by the lawyer
representing erci jaris petsikos that
looking into the evidence presented by
the prosecutor many of these charges
don't really stand up
for example one of the erci accused is
sarah mardini um the the swimmer from
syria who was at the time 23 years old
volunteering with the rci
and he told me that on many
of the the times and dates when she is
supposed to have been on in lesvos
breaking the law she was in fact in
germany
uh applying to university
so there seemed to be some some serious
problems with the case that government
is bringing forward john thank you
let's bring in our guest elizabeth
yorgos cosmopolis senior campaigner
on migration at amnesty international in
cambridge mayana karakolaki
and researcher focusing on refugees and
far-right movements in greece in
brussels peter klepp is editor of
brussels report eu welcome to the
program
yorgos you joined many other
international human rights organizations
describing the prosecution as absurd and
farcical
is it because of the very nature of the
charges or because the proceeding itself
is flawed
hi hi everyone um i just i just came out
of the court and i think it's both but
what is more important is farcical
because of the
things that they have accused of doing
uh basically what the greek government
is doing the greek authors is doing is
taking people who are doing good work
necessary work helping the authorities
helping the coast guard and drag them
through courts i saw it time and again
and i saw some today and of course on
the side i couldn't join um been
criminalized for doing a good thing and
that should not understand this trial
i've witnessed today stop never ever
have happened
mariana so what happened in between
these were aid workers operating in
lesbos helping refugees now the
government is saying wait a second
there's something that has to be
addressed these people were involved in
many many charges
uh so
basically the the
human trafficking is quite soft
because it can also differentiate
between solidarity and actual placement
trafficking i think in this case we have
a
case
peter many say this is a politically
motivated trial
to what extent are the
is the greek government taking advantage
of the divide within the european union
about migration to move forward with
this aggressive stance
uh well of course um it's a complex
issue um
i saw some of the charges include
fake license plates and then there's
indeed very serious uh charges as well
like human smuggling and espionage
um
it's hard to of course as an outsider to
to claim uh if these charges are
justified or not
but to the extent that um
criminalizing aid workers
uh is meant to sort of
stop some of the
the problems and the miss uh you know
the the miss pro miss situations over
there i i don't think it's the right uh
strategy to follow
i mean uh the thing is that
you you have a thin line between human
smuggling
and uh putting your boat somewhere
knowing that human smugglers would uh
you know abuse it so
i think it would be much more
much more sensible for the greek
government to say look we know that
you're willing to help
but
you have to restrict your activities to
these
areas because otherwise criminals will
take advantage of your of your good
intentions
that that's not
the strategy
you've been at the trial the the the
general prosecutor must have his own
justifications about the prosecution now
the case of sarah mardini the syrian
refugee and her sister had dragged a
boat to safety celebrated by the
international community as heroes now as
seen by the greek authorities
as
criminals who might
particularly sarah who might spend many
years behind bars
i think no one should be convinced that
sarah martinez criminal because it's
simply not sarah martin was someone who
who gave her private time a lot of her
personal time and commitment to come
here to lesvos where i stand to help the
people to help people in need she was
actually filling in a gap together with
sean and other rescuers when many very
often the the coast guard vessels or or
other vessels were actually calling upon
them to help them with cpr training with
getting people out of
the water sarah madini and the rest of
the people should be celebrated and
let's not just forget that sarah along
with song for example they spent three
months increases on because the
authorities the greek authorities
thought they are at risk of flight now i
just came out of the courtroom
and i was there but sarah could not be
there because the greek authorities
won't let her travel to greece to
participate in her own trial she wants
to come here she wants to show her face
because she's done nothing wrong i would
say not that's not nothing done nothing
wrong she's done a lot of good and she
should be celebrated and i think what
i've seen today is the opposite of that
is basically
part of a wider trend across europe to
criminalize helper to penalize aid
workers and at the end of the day it has
a very chilling effect not only lessons
but elsewhere everyone who's trying to
help everyone who's trying to act on
solidarity will
might have to think twice in doing so
and this is not only a moral but it's
also a legal responsibility
mariana could this trial be an
indication that the conservative
government in greece led by kiriakos
mitsutakis is
adamant about the need not to repeat
what happened in 2015 and 2016.
it's an example of uh the authoritarian
nature of uh the government of kiryakos
mitsutakis and we have seen that
everyone that is uh acting
against
the government's wills is
criminalized uh even though um the the
people who were arrested in 2018 were
arrested uh before kiriakos mitsutakis
uh he had he seems to have
exacerbated the power that he
that the government has over the legal
system and this is quite problematic to
be honest every single person that does
not agree with kiryakus mitsutakis
is is uh chased and targeted by an
online
herd of of trolls
and uh in the end they are being chased
out of outside of the current country
like what how like the example of the
dutch journalists that asked the
youngest mitchell attacks about
pushbacks
peter are we likely to see european
countries step in in this particular
case and say it's about time to give
justice to the
emergency response center international
and
the brave people who were working hard
day and night to help refugees
well i think this is all
a desperate attempt
to crack down on human smuggling and
indeed
i think we should put some crush
question marks uh around some of the
things that that are happening there
now um fundamentally the question is why
do we have all that human smuggling in
the in the first place
and
in in okay on occasion then human
smugglers use aid workers
for their purposes
now the answer is of course easy to
respond to it's because if you are an
asylum seeker and you want to
request asylum in europe there's hardly
any other route than to
to use human smugglers so i think that
that has to change
for now the eu's migration policies have
not managed to
to improve much
on that front
i think fundamentally we need to look at
very different approaches the one
currently explored by denmark is
actually quite interesting the idea is
that
there's a deal with the third country
where people can go can apply for asylum
you would have sort of safe corridors
from
you know refugee centers
in
in crisis areas so people no longer have
to use
human smuggling of course it would also
entail that if you illegally enter then
you would be brought to an offshore
processing center
i know there's a lot of criticism on
this australia has done it it has made
mistakes the conditions there were uh
were very bad
but there were also some successes in
the sense that
the number of drownings
from people trying to get into australia
has has has gone to virtually zero so
um obviously we have to tackle uh boats
you know we have to avoid that people
risk their lives
uh and and and drown at sea or are the
victim of all these gangs
but also if they then are welcomed in a
reception center of course the
conditions have to be
at high standards they need to get an
answer very quickly they should not be
there for
for too long
so yes i think that's the rule to follow
yoga uh sarah mardini
sean binder and the other aid workers
were traumatized by this experience and
by the charges brought about by the
uh by the by by the court what are the
options for them now in the future
well they have no option but to continue
to fight on against these charges this
charges must be dropped
the greek authorities must use the
opportunity of the the german of today's
uh
a child to be tried by a high court to
simply drop the charges they don't have
much problems and let's let's look at
the private cost of these people's lives
they are 25 26 years old
they they face the prospect of spending
25 years in prison for possibly the best
years of their life and they're still in
limbo what options do these people have
they're just put across through a system
which doesn't even allow them to come
and face this this observe the uh
accusations they'll have to fight we
have zamasu i'm gonna stand with them
all the way because as i said this case
is simply an example it's very example
of what's going on in europe and as far
as greece is concerned just goes to
seoul how far the greek authorities are
prepared to go to criminalize uh aid
workers and basically um keep people off
of the source and let's not forget it's
not only about humanitarian aid this
chilling effect towards a civil society
have other effects they're hardly any uh
independent and any observers at the
course of lesson
the cost of less loss and we need we
need observers we need people to to
verify facts and to be there to to offer
help so i do hope that sarah and sonam
are going to to fight on but we need to
fight with them and
i i would like also to say something
about her but the danish and the
australian proposals because it's very
pertinent to what has happened in legos
i don't think that's a good idea uh
solving the problem but disappearing
asylum seekers out of sight it's really
it's harder solution okay
we need to allow access to people give
them a fair procedure and by no means
europe has taken its fair share of
asylum seekers and refugees so the rest
i think is excuses so migration is a
very center of this particular case
mariana now you have the top eu
migration official
saying that we need migrants because
europe is aging and we have to show
solidarity you have the greek government
saying no it's about time to clamp on
the arrival of migrants and the case of
prosecution of those eight workers is a
clear message this divide itself this
disconnect is it likely to further
put more pressure on the migrants trying
to reach europe
migrants and asylum seekers will
continue trying to reach europe because
they're escaping conflict zones
those two differences uh between
the european union and
grace i don't think it's actually a real
difference because the european union is
fully aware about uh grace's tactics and
they seem to endorsing them not publicly
but the fact that
they're not stopping grace from
committing international
law crimes
is quite showing of uh its approach to
migration europe the european union does
not want uh refugees
peter one of the biggest problems here
is the european stance itself when it
comes to
welcoming the refugees and i think the
most contentious issue in particular was
should every country be obliged to
receive some refugees something which
has been dismissed by the hungarians and
by the polish government is this the
main reason why this is likely to
continue deepening the divide between
the european countries about migration
well i think it's true that
some of the things that we're seeing are
the result of public opinion in europe
that is indeed
very much against not so much migration
and asylum seekers but i would say
disorderly
migration flows
and especially the crisis in 2015 2016
has really traumatized public opinion so
that's why i think it's very important
for
proponents of migration and i include
myself among them especially i think
europe could definitely benefit from a
skilled
migration in happening in an orderly
manner while also obviously welcoming
asylum seekers
i think if you're in favor of that i
think you should realize how important
it is that it happens in an orderly way
and that's why
i i would like to see a lot more
attention for the danish for the
australian model
which are not perfect absolutely not and
and definitely should be improved
but
are absolutely not
meant to
avoid migration or avoid asylum seekers
but are meant to make sure it happens in
an orderly manner and this is
i can't stress how important this is and
actually the the case of going after aid
workers like my colleague said young
workers that
do this out of the good of their hearts
is i think a symptom of how a
traumatized public opinion can
can can engage in desperate measures
that are obviously not going to do much
to help border okay help with border
protection yeah but are are quite
questionable uh yogas we describe the
the the prosecution as farcical but the
environment itself in europe to what
extent it has been conducive to what
we're seeing now in greece because when
you look at
the center right it's embracing the same
steps taken by the file right the far
right is now on the rise you have a tv
far right of a pundit in france eric
zamor
who said that immigration was a threat
to the french identity is that
environment responsible for those
actions taken by countries particularly
by the greek government
well i think it's clear that has been
exceeding some
some sections of the public opinion i
still don't think that the public
opinion in europe in general is hostile
to migration though we have to to of
course be pragmatic and see that what
happened in 2015 was not all perfect and
the real issue here is how to organize a
system that is already obviously doesn't
put people's uh
at risk and that would begin by saving
legal rules so there has to be laptops
on the table which i think was mentioned
already it's not on the table refugees
now an asylum seeker cannot reach europe
in in
through safe and legal
uh groups and what we need to do at the
european level is have a system where
preferences and migrants can be
distributed evenly or fairly among
member states and must insist that
hungary and the rest who are actually
refusing to do so they should they
should
really
take in their
fair share again we are not going to go
against this uh
climate of sonophobia or races by
becoming more xenophobic ourselves for
approaching
the positions that they have been
expressed as we really have to stand on
ground will have to give the voice to
the people who really
want to see migration really want to
have open
society who are welcoming refugees and
migrants and then not following the trap
of uh shifting our views according to
that because there are also not only
human rights obligations that need to be
respected by the things like core values
of humanities at stake here in europe's
heart
i really appreciate your insight thank
you
and thank you two for watching you can
see the program again anytime by
visiting our website aljazeera.com for
further discussion go to our facebook
page that is facebook.com forward slash
aj inside story you can also join the
conversation on twitter our handle is at
aj inside story from mihash mahabharata
and the entire team here in doha bye for
now
[Music]
you